nos dicen que la enésima suma parcial de
la serie desde n igual a 1 hasta
infinito de n está dada por esta fórmula
la suma de los primeros n términos es
igual a n cuadrada más 1 entre n más uno
y nos preguntan cuál es el término 7 y
como siempre los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolver esto por
su cuenta una forma de pensar en ello es
ver cómo a 7 se relaciona con diferentes
sumas podemos decir que a uno más a dos
más a tres y voy a desarrollar todo más
a cuatro más a cinco más a seis más a
siete toda esta suma es ese siete y si
queremos encontrar a siete pues a esto
le voy a restar la suma de los primeros
seis términos pues a esto le voy a
restar la suma de los primeros seis
términos así que le restamos ese seis
así que nuevamente cuál es la estrategia
aquí conozco la fórmula para la suma de
los primeros n términos
y la puedo usar para encontrar la suma
de los primeros siete términos ese 7 que
es la suma de todos estos términos y
puedo usar la misma fórmula para
encontrar la suma de los primeros 6
términos y la diferencia entre ambas
sumas me va a dar el término que estoy
buscando a 7 otra forma de decir lo que
acabo de decir es que a 7 va a ser igual
a la suma de los primeros siete términos
ese 7 menos la suma de los primeros seis
términos ese 6 y si están resolviendo
esto por su cuenta no es necesario que
escriban todo esto que puse aquí yo lo
hice así para que esto fuera más claro
más intuitivo esto a que será igual ese
7 la suma de los primeros 7 términos
para encontrarla en donde haya una n la
vamos a reemplazar por un 7 así que nos
queda 7 al cuadrado más 1 entre 7 1 esto
es igual a 6 al cuadrado más 1 entre 61
y aquí sólo tenemos que hacer un poco de
aritmética esto es igual a menos 7 al
cuadrado
149 150 entre 8 y esto es 6 al cuadrado
36 más 137 entre 7 y aquí queremos
encontrar un común denominador de 8 y 7
iba a ser 56 así que esto es algo entre
56 - u otra cosa entre 56 y ahora para
pasar de 8 a 56 multiplique por 7 así
que el numerador también lo tengo que
multiplicar por 750 por 7 es 350 y en
esta fracción multiplique el denominador
por 8 así que tengo que multiplicar el
numerador por 8 37 por 8 va a hacer 240
más 56 lo que nos da a 296 así que esto
va a ser igual a algo cuyo denominador
es 56 350 menos 296 va a ser igual a 54
así que de 54 entre 56 y si queremos
simplificar esto nos va a quedar 27
entre
28 y ya no lo puedo simplificar más y
este es el valor de a 7 es la diferencia
entre la suma de los primeros 7 términos
menos la suma de los primeros 6 términos